au chili ont fait le retour à la vie
normale des 33 mineurs bloqués sous
terre pendant 69 jours ici à copiapo on
célèbre comme il se doit le retour chez
lui du mineur le plus âgé mario gomez 63
ans
tout va bien et moi bien je suis très
ému c'est normal tous se précipitent
dans la petite maison familiale pour
féliciter embrasser effleuré mario gomez
son épouse elle ne s'attendait pas à une
telle ferveur
je suis très touchée très et lui aussi
je ne m'attendais pas à une si belle
réception pour lui
dans une autre maison du village ces
mêmes scènes de liesse de ferveur de
joie qui se répète ici chez cet autre
mineur ariel ticona avec son fils dans
les bras il est accueilli en véritable
héros
je vais bien je récupère je suis avec
mes amis les voisins et toute la famille
mais vous restez
toujours dans ce petit village de
copiapo cette même ferveur et émotion
chez un autre enfant du pays victor
segovia durant les deux mois passés sous
terre il a noirci des feuilles de papier
pour raconter son expérience
j'ai écrit pour mes amis et pour ma
famille à ma part
sur les 33 mineurs du puits de san jose
seuls deux d'entre eux devront encore
patienter quelques heures avant de
pouvoir faire la fête il souffre de
vertiges et de maux de tête